holden underwood's first he first
appeared as a contestant on the bachelor
in 2018
and then became the bachelor himself in
2019
after a tumultuous relationship with
cassie and eventually breaking up last
year colton was on good morning america
this morning
to reveal that he is gay
i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm gay and
i came to terms with that earlier this
year and have been processing it
and the next step in all of this was
sort of
letting people know still nervous but um
yeah it's it's been a journey for sure
through the nerves i can see the joy
i can't see the relief i mean i'm
emotional but i'm emotional in like such
a good happy positive way
um i'm like the happiest and healthiest
i've ever been in my life
do i regret being the bachelor and do i
regret
handling it the way that i did i do um
i do think i could have handled it
better i'll say that how so
i just i just wish i wouldn't have
dragged people into my own mess of
figuring out who i was
i i genuinely mean that
but i also at the same time like but i
can sit here and say i'm sorry to all of
those women i can also say thank you
because without them and without the
bachelor franchise
i don't know if i like this would have
ever came out were you in love with
cassie
yes i mean and that only made it harder
and more confusing for me
i fully was a virgin before that and i
could never give anybody a good enough
answer of why i was a virgin
the truth is i was a virgin bachelor
because i was gay
i got closer to god this year and
i know even saying that now as a gay man
people can be like how's that even
possible and it's like
i don't think unless you understand i
used to wake up in the morning and pray
for him to take the gay away i used to
pray for him
to change me and i can now wake up and
pray to god and i can actually have
faith and i can go into church and
be present
all right so some reaction as well so
chris harrison who may or may not
still be the host of the bachelor after
he sympathized with a bachelor of
contestants racist past
but he did post uh very proud of you
today colton
happy to see you stand up and openly
live your truth give my love and support
my friend
uh yeah and dan levy tweeted coming out
can be a terrifying uncomfortable and
traumatizing experience
because we still live in a world where
we are made to fear the consequences of
living freely
let that sink in so happy for colton his
courage will undoubtedly save lives
today
yeah vasario says so happy for colton no
surprise at all knew he was gay
um uh ali says he still seems
uncomfortable with talking about it
he also is sad that people hate
themselves for being gay that's a whole
other aspect to this uh jeff you know
the fact he was
came from such religious background yeah
what's your reaction him
coming out well if it's one thing that
i think 2020 showed me and a lot of
people is when the world slowed down
you got to face yourself without any
distractions or anything and you got to
discover
who you were who you want to be how
you're going to evolve and how you're
going to make a change so
anyone on a journey when you're able to
discover yourself
and you're able to accept yourself love
yourself
and evolve in that way i'm all for it
and you who knows
only he knows but that burden that was
on him for whatever to perform for
whatever gaze that he had to
for him to be able to finally show and
be his true self
i'm all i'm all for that and i think
it's horrible to have those societal
pressures religious pressures
on you and it really holds you down so
if he's feels unencumbered by that now
i'm all for that
the other side i kind of think about
think about the the women that were on
the show you know at least they could
say now i knew it wasn't
you don't say like you could freaking
have some something that wasn't
but i know there may be confusion and
anger and all those emotions involved
and i'm glad to see him
apologize and be contrite with that um
and so it can give him some sense
because you know we're not
we're all fallible people so i don't i
don't i think you
for them they're gonna have to decide if
if that's sufficient for
for them but overall if he's not living
a lie within himself anymore
i support it yeah yeah and i think that
this
maybe and maybe it's a reach shed some
light on the way that he and cassie
resolve things because
the bachelor nation is a fickle group
and there's a lot of people today saying
that he didn't say enough
about cassie and he what even what he
said with coming out didn't excuse
um the allegations against him that she
made with the stalking charges the
harassments the text messages
the putting a tracker in her car and
when that all sort of went away
it would they it was revealed that they
had a conversation and now i'm wondering
if this was part of this conversation if
maybe this was
something that cassie has known uh has
known for a while and colton is only now
uh is only now coming out with it but it
was it was it was when it was
announced that he was going to be on the
show um he's somebody who splits black
bachelor nation
right down the middle um ever since the
you know
the severe focus on him being a virgin
on the show which now of course
all makes sense and he was the guy who
did the fence jump you know like there
was like that entire
episode was based around the fence jump
and now everything just sort of starts
to
starts to make sense right yeah uh luis
says he needs to apologize line item
by line item for what he did to cassie
yes he says he still seems nervous you
can hear every time he swallows
i mean it's a big deal to come into the
closet and say those words
he knows he's saying these words on
national television so of course he's
going to be nervous
i have a few things to say about this so
bear with me i mean everyone's on the
right journey i mean
he's 29 years old everyone's story is
different like i put no fault on colton
for
you know waiting till he's 29 like i was
29 just before i turned 30 actually
that actually told my family that i was
gay even though i'd been out at work
even though i've been out with friends
but
yeah like my family's kind of a separate
thing so i didn't tell them until right
before i turned 30. so
you have to get comfortable with it and
going back to the idea we've had this
conversation a few times over the last
two weeks about representation
that people will comment on here saying
why does it matter if someone comes out
of the closet like who cares at this
point
it absolutely matters like i mean he was
a football player i mean there's still
the stigma in sports that people aren't
gay
in in sports so the fact that him coming
out of the closet is going to change
lives like he was saying he was ready to
kill himself
because he was gay so the fact that he's
coming out of the closet as a football
player someone who's in sports
that is going to change lives and i
think how much
things have changed in the last 20 years
like i remember when i was a teenager
i thought i couldn't be gay because the
only representations i was seeing of gay
people
were the stereotypical flamboyant types
like i remember seeing will and grayson
thinking
i'm not like jack i'm not like will so i
can't be gay and so
the fact we're seeing all these other
representations of what it means to be
in the lgbtq community
it is a huge huge thing for people to
come into the closet so for people to
say it doesn't matter like
why are people coming out of this gay it
absolutely changes things the other
thing i will say
that this bachelor franchise
i mean it is so archaic at this point
like i don't understand
why people support this franchise
anymore we we know how it treats women
behind the scenes
so i don't get how it survived the metoo
movement we know now that
he was so behind in diversity so behind
an inclusion
they finally had a black bachelor and
they somehow casted
a woman who had attended antebellum uh
parties just a couple years ago
and he ends up choosing her now we have
this idea that a guy was trying to use
this to
sell himself as straight i'm not
faulting colton in any kind of way
but the fact that people are still
supporting this franchise this franchise
needs to die
it is not helping society in any kind of
way even the basic premise when that
show first came out
it's a terrible premise that towards
women that you're all competing for one
guy's affection so the fact that
i hope this makes people realize and
media outlets that cover the show
every other day this is not a show that
you should be showcasing
there i've done my rant yeah i think i
think people agree no i i i think people
agree with you the show is broken
and once the veil has you know has been
lifted off
of the of the bachelor there's no
putting it back on once you've seen
behind
the curtain of the bachelor there's
there's no forgetting what you saw
but i just don't know if people care
and i think that that's part odds
yeah yeah i just don't know and if they
do care maybe they just don't care
enough
you know like it's i don't think it's
lost on people
but i think that they're willing to
overlook because this is three
four hours of their week that they get
to pretend that it's not what it
actually is and what we all know it to
be
and i think that that's what makes the
bachelor the success that it is
we all know everybody knows
about jeff like should this franchise
still be around well i'll say as
somebody who got
newly initiated into bachelor nation
with
with uh matt james i don't know how
y'all been doing it the last few years
this is stressed man like all of these
these married shows bachelor shows
i'm just like wow i feel like i have
a a cloud over me every time i watch but
then i get the appeal of reality tv
when the appeal of reality tv dies then
franchise like this will die
but if you see with tick tock and
instagram that's the reality tv for this
generation
where you get to see people live their
lives and do cool things that you may
want to do
and that escapism is something that
people will buy into
more than the the behind the scenes
drama because that might even fuel it
so when you have though that harm
inflicted and all those things going on
it's it's on those same fans to demand
better
because if you want to have escapism you
want to kind of have it the right way
like just a little dab of mess not the
whole pot
just a little bit of seasoning and
nothing that's destructive
yeah you feel a little bit gross but now
at this point this franchise just feels
like
it's so toxic like i don't know how
anyone hears it but uh two weeks to each
their own to a certain extent but yeah
like
that's happened with yours yeah okay